the Joe Rogan experience yeah I'm not
complaining on the BJ Penn fight I
remember the first one in Abu Dhabi I
was there for that one oh yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah you know that was those a big
victory man and yes I would want those
big yet if the second one was probably
even better just because I you know
mortally one you know and I felt like -
like you know BJ had my back in the in
that second fight and you know I thought
you know get your back back then you're
in trouble and if it would defend I
think it reversed them so I kind of
showed a little bit of all my complete
skills in that fight and all the guys
that I've ever seen fighter never seen
anybody who controls people with the
legs the way BJ does he's got the
craziest dexterity on his legs he does I
heard when he was younger he could stand
up and put his leg over his head
standing up Jesus cry I don't know if
that's true
like just lift it up not even grabbing
and not even grab that's true seem jump
out of the pool - that's pretty wild
ya know he's incredible athlete yeah and
his his physical talents were unusual
but he worked on it like this other
thing a lot of people don't realize like
there's some great videos of BJ
stretching and he would stretch with
bands so he has all this crazy like he
would grab his foot like put her on his
chest he's got bands and stretch the
[ __ ] out himself so it wasn't just
natural ability it was also like he'd
realized well he realized that his legs
were like other arms like because he
when you were in his guard he would just
those legs would come up and just pinch
you down and and his mount he would
cross his legs and meet dudes and his
back mount was incredible yeah he was
one of a kind I think you know on the
ground and just as a fighter I mean I
looked up to him coming up you know he
was the man like him licking blood off
his hands you know I mean I was actually
with him we were each did the UFC gym 10
year anniversary
up in Concord and BJ was there so I was
hanging out BJ be just good dude man we
get along really well is uh is he is he
done fighting or was he gonna do um I
don't I think he wants to fight I don't
think Dana wants him to fight but uh I'm
pretty crazy brawl in Hawaii yeah yeah
people are also like I'll look at pizza
you're getting mad at a fighter for
fighting I
you know come on is it that surprising
this is a funny way to look at it right
like of a singer get a fight with a
fighter fighting is like a basketball
player having a pickup get exactly can't
get mad and over that it is kind of
weird when you stop and think about it
you know I mean that's the nature down
in Hawaii I think a lot of people get
down that's how they get down over there
yeah they get down yeah tough
[ __ ] in Hawaii yeah for sure
you know that fight that was so sad to
watch like that Duke Lipton with the
left hook and dropped him and bounced
his head off the concrete look like [ __ ]
did he say hit me he said yes he let I
hit him and then he came back he went
out he flashed out and went down and
then I don't know if the video was
continuous or what but later is a video
of him having a guy's back smash them
sigh god damn yeah and you gotta be
kidding you never know a gap in the
street fight so yeah guys go home open
the trunk come right back yeah that way
I mean should throw some on their head
and they don't wake up that's a big one
yeah you know that happened to a buddy
mine in Long Island Kevin James actually
the the comedian yeah his his buddy
well he they were working together as
bouncers and he was working with this
guy and this guy got a fight with a
patron punched the guy knocked him out
the guy fell banged his head off the
ground died wow dude wound up doing jail
time Wow and that happens I heard a
story of some wrestler kind of same
thing
gondol fight people guy up slamming his
head and end up in jail oh my god he
imagine a wrestler like a Doyle Romero
how can sue flexing you on the street in
a well and the [ __ ] that's it's over
forever
absolutely yeah he'll flatten the top of
your head
[Applause]